[Música]
soy
y esto compensó
yo sé bien que no estarás cuando me
vayan y aunque te duela más aprender de
esto
pienso llorar
te sientes
que quien tiene sra
siente
es bien
ese es el tema principal de la
telenovela leonela transmitida por radio
caracas televisión en 1983
lionel a es una joven comprometida con
otro otro le da una golpiza a pedro luís
el protagonista y pedro luís en venganza
se viola a leonela obviamente y dónde la
queda embarazada él va a la cárcel y
cuando sale ella se enamora de su
violador y se casan
en términos de política sería como decir
que llega un militar y a la fuerza trata
de tumbar al gobierno electo y como no
lo logra va a la cárcel y cuando sale el
pueblo le da su voto en elecciones y
luego no no importa lo que pase el
pueblo luego la guerra por siempre
las historias que nos contamos nos
construyen
no importa si son reales o ficticias
solo importa como nos vinculamos
emocionalmente con estas historias y la
frecuencia con la que las consumimos
imagínense el poder de una sola historia
contada como si fuera un mantra día tras
día
durante décadas
a toda una nación o incluso a todo un
continente
permítanme compartir con ustedes el que
considero muy representativo ejemplo de
lo que es el poder de la ficción
desde hace casi 70 años en venezuela las
familias tenían en la sala de su casa un
televisor y ahí entraban principalmente
dos canales y en ambos se transmitía
durante varias horas del día telenovelas
eso era dos telenovelas en el almuerzo y
dos telenovelas en la cena
en la época en la que se almorzaba y se
cenaba
por muchos años fuimos de los más
grandes exportadores de telenovelas del
mundo y de ser un gran orgullo para el
país petróleo misses y telenovelas
si quería ser actriz y además pagar sus
cuentas con tu carrera de actuación
había que trabajar en algunas
telenovelas
'mea culpa'
y a decir verdad no solamente era muy
entretenido grabar las escenas sino
también muy gratificante ver cómo
descubrir en carne propia cómo gran
parte del país e incluso el extranjero
adoraban estas novelas y bueno también
el trabajo de uno en ellas
en la historia de la televisión
venezolana ha habido unas telenovelas
más interesantes y originales que otras
pero en el género más fuerte siempre ha
sido la telenovela rosa
esta es la sinopsis de la telenovela
rosa contada una y otra vez
la chica pobre humilde trabajadora que
no tiene donde caerse muerta llamémosla
rubí tan linda tan inocente y frágil
ella se enamora de un chico honesto y
buena gente que llamaremos víctor
alfonso
y resulta ser el hijo de una millonaria
maluquis ima la villana elegantísima y
adinerada sima que llamaremos lucrecia
durante muchos episodios lucre s y sus
séquitos maltratan a la pobre rubí la
engaña la manipula la viola se burlan la
humilla
cada historia a lo suyo pero a la mitad
de la telenovela hay una revelación o
una herencia que fue corrompida usurpada
no se le entregó a quien correspondía a
la chica pobre a ruby ella era la
verdadera heredera de toda la fortuna de
esa mansión
pero la malévola lucrecia muy hija de
mente se la robó la historia avanza
hay un giro
y rubí recupera milagrosamente la
herencia robada y de un capítulo a otro
simplemente ha cambiado el peinado el
maquillaje el vestuario se vuelve de
alcurnia
y ejerce la venganza contra la villana y
contra todos los que se burlaron de ella
la gente en su casa pega al televisor
con la boca llena de arepas como si se
tratara de su propia vida y le están
hablando al espejo gritaban años y en mí
está bien hecho hay ahora si lo logro
hay ahora que pague esa que sufra la
malvada
50 años
de telenovela rosa
sin siquiera imaginarlo prepararon el
terreno para que el discurso del
teniente coronel hugo rafael chávez
frías calada profundamente en los
venezolanos
porque la trama de estos culebrón es la
volvíamos a consumir pero ahora en forma
de alocución presidencial también por
varios años y durante largas horas en
cadena nacional
esta vez nos la contaban así
chica pobre humilde pata en el suelo
llamémosla el pueblo
se enamora de un chico
con esto y buena gente que a efecto de
estas actitudes llamaremos el teniente
coronel y será él quien se le voltear a
alhama la millonaria a la villana que
llamaremos la oligarquía
lo cierto es que surge una revelación
la oligarquía le han robado todo lo que
le pertenece al pueblo quien era la
verdadera heredera de toda la fortuna de
esta mansión llamada venezuela
hay un giro esta vez es el protagonista
el teniente coronel quien se le voltea a
la madre poderosa y hace que la
multimillonaria herencia regrese a manos
de la verdadera heredera el pueblo
lo truculento y malsano de esta historia
y de todas estas telenovelas
es el hecho de que se le despierte a
ruby al pueblo la sed de venganza contra
la oligarquía
despertada intencionalmente por su amado
teniente
y con el paso del tiempo de discurso en
discurso los villanos las lucrecia se
fueron multiplicando porque se fue
incluyendo allí a prácticamente todo
aquel que tuviera un poquito más que la
chica pobre de hecho se llegó un punto
en que la villana era simplemente todo
aquel que no estuviera del lado
el chico honesto y buena gente el
teniente coronel
y así en esta versión la villana la
oligarquía se ha vuelto un gentil
es la clase alta y la clase media es la
cuarta república la oposición el imperio
la iglesia los medios de comunicación la
empresa privada los inversionistas
extranjeros los empleados petroleros los
sindicatos los profesores los
estudiantes
y así cualquiera que no sea la chica
pobre ni el teniente coronel
y no sé qué pasa con esta versión de la
historia
que no fueron felices para siempre
y que claro el discurso de la revolución
bolivariana al igual que la telenovela
rosa se disfrazaban de amor pero lo que
realmente hablaban era el resentimiento
de envidia de rencor
en definitiva de odio
estas telenovelas rosa se transmiten en
venezuela desde la primera telenovela
venezolana la cría a la granja en 1953
hasta incluso hoy aunque ya no se
producen telenovelas en venezuela por la
situación se está transmitiendo en
horario estelar una bien rosa grabada en
miami llamada acorralada
con su respectiva herencia robada y su
respectiva venganza
año 2020 y en televisión abierta en
venezuela se siguen viendo telenovelas
rosas
claro los días que hay electricidad
y entre esta primera y esta última hay
un montón de éxitos y si más telenovelas
que cumplen a cabalidad este patrón solo
por mencionar algunas entre mexicanas
maya meras y venezolanas están
rosas salvajes gata salvaje corazón
salvaje corazón indomable alma indomable
la indomable pobre diabla cara sucia el
desprecio yo compro esa mujer valentina
carolina sabrina rosa linda marimar
cristal topacio esmeralda rubí rebelde
mi gorda bella las dos dianas late área
ni está la dama de rosa la dueña la
revancha la venganza
siempre la misma historia
la pobre la rica maltrato herencia
venganza
cuando le preguntaban a los gerentes de
televisión oye por qué siempre esa misma
trama con ese mensaje de venganza
respondía
el conde de montecristo un clásico de la
literatura universal al que le hacemos
homenaje
para que harían falta tantos homenajes
para una sola historia no llegaban
escritores con ganas de contar algo
nuevo hay que darse hacemos una
telenovela de ruptura diferente no sea
un concepto más original que transmita
valores
pero casi siempre la respuesta era nada
eso no sube cerro
con esta frase se referían a que era
fundamental ser sintonizados por las
clases más bajas y esta trama siempre
esa trama les habían garantizado rating
y con rating se aseguraban a los
anunciantes en venezuela vio la eterna
competencia entre dos canales de
televisión y esa competencia definía la
programación
de vez en cuando asumían el riesgo y se
salían de la fórmula a veces con éxitos
fulgurantes pero otras veces con
fracasos estrepitosos así que siempre
recurrían a la trama que sabían que
subiría a cero
con estas observaciones no pretendo
señalar a la televisión como responsable
de lo que ha pasado en el país por
supuesto que no este es un elemento
cultural entre muchos factores además se
trataba de empresas privadas haciendo lo
que consideraban lo mejor para sus
negocios siguiendo la tendencia lo que
se producía y se consumía en toda
latinoamérica y además recibiendo el
espaldarazo del resto del planeta que
compraba sus producciones
pero si quiero que una gran
subestimación del alcance masivo y del
poder formativo de estas horas de ocio y
entretenimiento
podemos pensar que las ficciones que
creamos son producto de la cultura que
nos rodea
acaso no será al revés no será que
nuestra cultura
el resultado de estas historias que nos
contamos estoy segurísima de que habrán
millones y millones de ejemplos como
esta en cada país en cada pueblo de como
ese rato de ocio y entretenimiento
diario nos definen profundamente como
individuos y como sociedad
eeuu por ejemplo un país con cultura de
reality shows y celebrities bueno
escogieron de presidente es un personaje
que ha llevado sus campañas y su
gobierno como si se tratara de un
reality show
o qué tal si dejamos la política a un
lado el caso del crecimiento exponencial
de nuevos estudiantes en la carrera
paleontología al año siguiente del
estreno de 'jurassic park' o aún más
reciente en españa del 2018
hubo un incremento de estudiantes esta
vez de filosofía y todo señala a la
buena influencia de la serie catalana
merlín
que trata sobre la relación de un
profesor de filosofía con sus
estudiantes
somos lo que consumimos para bien y para
mal
es por eso que es fundamental reconocer
el poder de las historias que nos
contamos el poder de la ficción
habría que preguntarnos como
espectadores
que estamos consumiendo constantemente
qué programas vemos
aquí le seguimos en redes sociales en
que ponemos nuestra atención justo
cuando estamos relajados
cuando bajamos la guardia
y para los que de alguna forma contamos
historias que hoy en día con las nuevas
tecnologías somos prácticamente todos
imaginemos
qué cuento podríamos echarnos
de veces de ahora en adelante para que
el mundo sea mejor
muchas gracias
[Aplausos]